hey guys the ninth of October today and
it's a Friday which means I've got the
five biggest stories of this week to get
you all caught up research group Nielsen
has come back with the results of the
study to determine what is the most
anticipated holiday release game and
Felina fallout 4 didn't top the list
call duty black ops 3 1 the top slot
closely followed by fallout 4 Assassin's
Creed syndicate and need for speed solos
Battlefront rise of the Tomb Raider and
rock band 4 rounded out the most
anticipated multi-platform list the most
anticipated Wii U game was Yoshi's
woolly world and on PC it's a starcraft
2 legacy of the void halo 5 guardians
tops the popularity charts for xbox one
and on ps4 the winner was uncharted than
nathan drake collection the data was
collected from a survey of 4800 gamers
of varying ages and featured games must
have had a release date between the
start of October and the end of December
destiny players had a reason to get
riled up this week as it was announced
the game is going to get
microtransactions Bungie announced that
players can now purchase 18u emotes
using silver a new in-game currency that
is purchasable with your real-world
funds but they quickly clarified that
said micro transactions will in no way
affect the call games mg have said the
micro transactions are optional but
they'll be slipping all players a few
silver for free to grab themselves in a
motor to when they go on sale pricing
information is yet to be announced but
you'll find out what they cost when the
emotes become available in-game come
October 13 if you're stuck for something
to do this weekend you may want to have
a go at star wars battlefront as the
beta is now live and open to all the
beta is available across pc ps4 and xbox
one and it's going to run until October
12 you'll be able to try your hand at a
single or co-op survival mission as well
as the 40 player Walker assault and drop
zone modes if you like you can also
check out the battlefront companion
experience to earn items than a main
game it seems there may be a pretty good
market for the uncharted collection as
naughty dog have revealed that eighty
percent of ps4 owners have never played
an uncharted game Naughty Dog's Eric
monacelli told MCV we did a lot of
research and discovered that about
eighty percent of the people that own a
ps4 have never played uncharted period
that was one of the reasons why we
thought remastering it would be a good
idea previously sony has discovered that
almost fifty percent of ps4 owners never
owned a ps3 monacelli added that Naughty
Dog has high expectations for the Nathan
Drake collection which hits shelves
today
finally this week after hours upon hours
of live streaming a cave wall Ubisoft
finally announced Far Cry primal the new
entry in the open world shooter series
will ditch the guns be set in 10,000 BC
during the Stone Age and will be a
full-priced standalone title Ubisoft
have said to expect saber-tooth Tigers
mammoths and warring tribes the reveal
trailer depicts the player bringing down
a mammoth with Spears and arrows
alongside a hunting party far cry primal
is set to launch on februari 23 of next
year for ps4 xbox one and pc let me know
down in that comment box what you cared
about this week and which game you're
most excited to play this holiday season
this week on site I tell you about six
awesome single-player FPS campaigns on
the chest Lucy gives you the lowdown on
metal gear online on in two minutes and
our floor mop floor show tucks into the
craziest fall out factions that is
everything I have you this week be sure
to have yourselves a great weekend too
with or without Battlefront and I will
see you again on Monday